discussion elle va être débattu par les
députés communistes demain je crois que
les députés de la france ont soumis se
sont réunis aujourd'hui les députés
communistes ils sont onze vont se réunir
demain et c'est eux qui vont prendre qui
vont prendre cette décision
ce qui est certain c'est que dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes donc
à un parlement archi dominé par macro
nous allons être convergents dont on
travaille sur beaucoup de choses donc il
serait il faut trouver des formes de
travail commune est ce que ça pourra
aller jusqu'au groupe commun c'est les
députés qui vont en discuter et qui vont
après ont discuté entre eux les démonter
de la france est soumise à des députés
comme une carrière votre avis vous moi
la disposition de travail qui sera la
meilleure la plus efficace pour faire du
commun et qui permettent à chacune des
sensibilités de pouvoir de pouvoir
s'exprimer
voilà sera la meilleure dont fodil faut
disent qu'il faut y arriver est arrivé
c'est ça en plus je sais c'est sérieux
ce que je vais vous dire je je pense
qu'effectivement les députés moi je suis
sous ceux de sa ici dans le groupe a au
sénat quand on a ces questions à
discuter son voilà prennent leurs
responsabilités par les mauves ont parlé
entre eux et vont chercher je vous dis
là meilleures dispositions possibles
ça ne va pas faire dit nous avons
beaucoup de choses je le répète à féron
comment ça ne va pas faire disparaître
du jour au lendemain les débats que nous
avons eus pendant l'élection
présidentielle et que nous aurons
peut-être demain avec la france sera
soumise
alors on va écouter jean